I have Brian Urlacher finishing 12th in
the Heisman Trophy balloting he had five
first-place votes coming out of college
Brian Urlacher joins us now is that
right 12th in the Heisman Trophy
balloting I would not know the answer to
that question wait you didn't even know
that you're right you know oh did you
say ethical state earlier somebody other
sorry I couldn't understand I think I
wrestle with you I apologized a minute
yeah it's it did what you did it I just
want to make sure you know I'm
clarifying could you played offense in
the NFL I think I would have started
there I think I could have or move very
early in my career but I really like
defense um well yeah I think it you know
you know some guys in there on the goal
line and whatever you know well they're
doin those trick plays down there
blocking but you're not blocking you're
releasing so I would like to down
something like that
I didn't catch a pass one pass well you
could have been a tight end at that size
and athleticism I'm sort of a receiver
so I really like blocking so perfect
receiver right where did you get your
athleticism from I was lucky you know I
I'm my parents are big no one in my
family is really big
we're all decent athletes but I have no
idea I think you know I started working
out when I was 13 years old and doing
power cleans and squats and I just kept
growing and get stronger and the more
athletic less you do those that's like
gonna get so I think they had a lot to
do with it as well but you started out
as a safety mm-hmm and then all of a
sudden you go to being a linebacker I
mean did you ever think that you could
have played safety in the NFL you know
I'd like to say yes but I don't know I
don't know like if I could cover tight
ends I think it running backs
I don't had our time with the slot
receiver I'm not good to say that
I got matched up a few times on them in
our defense and it's not a knot
situation I like to be in but you know I
think a range wise I think I could have
done it I would have had to lose some
weight I was into 40 shots out of
college I could have played an NFL to 35
or to 30 at safety
get out while you look at Darren Woodson
yeah those guys those guys could play
they're bigger guys
how important is a first-ballot Hall of
Fame to you I know you're one of the
final 15 finalists but how important is
to go in first ballot honestly I have no
expectations dan you know I've talked to
I know I didn't ask you one about this I
haven't reached out but some guys have
reached out to me about what the process
is like having an idea hook goes but
some guys have reached out to me and
just like just enjoy the process they
say whatever happens you know what I've
done is not going to change on the
football field so now it's kind of out
of my hands and up to the voters so I
have no expectations it's very humbling
and honoring it's an honor to be in this
position and never expected to be here
when I had when I start playing it's
pretty cool what Aaron Rodgers said to
the Chicago Tribune how about that did
you know that you were his favorite
player because I had a great time I mean
we had some great conversations between
play sometimes during plays his
favorites you know so it was useful fun
to play against you know what kind of
compare he is loves wants to win always
trying to win just like I felt like I
was but we had some great games and some
great cat-and-mouse games blind
scrimmage did you ever hit him I mean
hard yeah I did actually
2009 a year broke I dislocated my wrist
I got even the first quarter back when
you could hit quarterback superfine
today too but back then it was a known
as a good yet alright here's the quote
Aaron Rodgers said this to Brad Biggs in
the Chicago Tribune that Brian Urlacher
is one of my favorite if not my favorite
player because he is hyper competitive
tough human and does it the right way
plays with a lot of passion a lot of
grit a lot of class I always enjoyed our
battles yeah you can almost get
emotional with that pretty cool you know
a good player his caliber when he's done
they're coming from again like that so
pretty cool maybe you could have him
introduce you at the Hall of Fame when
you get in let's say if I get okay who
would you have dude in a good friend I'm
not sure I go that far yeah he's a
quarterback he plays for the Packers
that's why I wouldn't go over too well
with the bears nation how does it affect
do you think the balloting your chance
to go in with Ray Lewis being on the
ballot at the same time at the same
position you know I don't know I've
heard we were watching some some
shoulder and now they're talking about
that that's gonna hurt me because I
definitely think racist on holiday for
him Randy I think are slammed onto my
opinion I would never say that about
myself so no and that's why we've said
about themselves either so I don't know
it's just it's up to the lawyers I guess
I'm not sure how the process works I
know there's someone that goes in there
in that room I before and kind of
battles for you or kind of plead your
case says why you should be in the Hall
of Fame so my guys I think Dan Pompey so
I had a lot of confidence in him okay he
knows a lot of us football and he was in
Chicago my whole career so I'm in good
hands that you buy in Erlanger the
former Bears all-pro linebacker and one
of the finalists final 15 for the Hall
of Fame I was watching some highlights
when you know the first came out with
the nominees final 15 and it showed Ray
Lewis and it showed you and what stood
out is the form tackling that you guys
had it wasn't about blowing people up
that you guys and Ray was one of the you
know toughest guys obviously and so were
you but it was form tackling you know I
think there's a time and a place when
you take your shots at guys but there's
not always gonna be grateful you know we
put ourselves in positions to make those
tackles I think more than not you know
so we were able to make good form
tackles whatever they did ensure bad you
know our tackles were like there to get
them down either over where you get ran
over and pull the guy down I had a few
of those as well so you know I think
when you get in certain positions just
get the guy on the ground but and we
tell how to tackle since we were nine
years old so we should know how to do it
by then and there's a reason we uh I
think we're top 15 finalists right
what's the one play that you just hope
they don't show with your career oh gosh
no but there has to be one there has to
be one cringe-worthy one where you just
go I'll give you about five right over
by Brandon Jacobs twice I got duped by
Tom Brady
I got shook by
who was that that got me real it was a
receiver did just got me really good a
kid member cool was but I almost want to
show those toys honestly because I know
alright I gonna show you how you almost
want to show your bad lazing about you
know what I'm human all my plays were
unbelievable and I want my kids to see
that you know and not everything's gonna
go great all the time but there are some
times where I believe it now I didn't do
what I was supposed to do and the Brady
play oh boy you know I wouldn't do this
now if it was 37
they're in the they're in the red zone
they're almost 25 and if we stop them
they kick a field goal or trying to
abilities and I if I tackle them with
5:13 for any Jukes me and I get the
first time they end up score touchdown
I'm serious I was just that ones the
stickers alright I'm kidding man over is
whatever I got rid of her from a tree
also I'm watching this it feels like
it's it's fake like it's CGI that that
they they put Brady in there like he's
celebrating and he's doing the
first-down thing oh yeah no way no way
no don't try that Ryan don't try to tell
me you run backwards a 40-yard dash
faster than Brady growing up I think Tom
had like a for nine or five side he goes
you looking very fast achill he was fast
enough
yeah those five rings work maybe if
possible six this year thoughts on the
Bears as they move forward
you got any and be excited about I was
you know watching mister I was super
excited this is the most excited I've
been during the season watching them
since I retired you know Mitch was
coming around there at the end
I was excited about next year and this
hi Fox no I I feel like they're going on
the right direction and I'm not sure if
keeping Fox or Firefox was the right
move out I don't know anything about
that stuff I know if you had a couple
more years of this kid or that
cuz I think they'd have been better but
you know it's like they had to make a
move I'm so excited about where they're
they got a great defensive line great
offensive line if they get a couple
receivers healthy or maybe some big-name
receivers a receiver I think they'll be
better often their running back so yeah
they're good turnout are just awesome
yeah there are a lot of fun
are your kids playing on the watch are
you kids playing football yes my son
plays tackle for the first year this
year what did mom think of that oh you
know you wanted to play how much you can
say about it you know I told her I said
look just going in they're going to get
hurt it's just a matter of winning how
bad he knows that it's just you know how
much do you want to put out there but um
he he enjoyed it um you know was this
first year so I kind of felt this way
through but he did get more aggressive
during into the season so I'm excited
about that what if he wanted to be
quarterback yeah yeah I'll be awesome
[Laughter]
how's the hair looking oh man I need a
haircut so bad Dan I was it's not it's
good it's really good restore did me
good but it's uh that's long right now
it's like the longest has been you got
to put it in a ponytail is it is it like
Clay Matthews I have so many cowlicks
and it just those 65 different
directions so it's just uh just it's not
good it's good but it's not good but
you're you're you're a guy with hair
problems now you never had that before
massive hair problems yeah you know I
tons of shampooing my hair so I'm going
to show it does to my getting ready uh
sure
good luck here in the next couple of
weeks and we'll catch up with you again
thanks for joining us hi buddy it's
Brian Urlacher for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you